i just wish we could redo
this whole night so that you could see
how wrong you are
yeah i wish we could redo the whole
night so we can see how wrong you
are
oh god we're getting good drinks
good night everyone
lisa and i had an argument last night
and then to figure out who was right we
decided to do over the entire night
exactly the way it was so that's why
we're here
[Music]
oh yeah and sarah wanted to leave i was
tired i just wanted to give you a ton
then trina got herself another drink oh
god
trina what are you doing we're gonna
find out who's right
[Music]
hello we're going to find out who's
right
of course you do no more hugging oh
i can't drink it anymore i have to drink
trainer
ready pick trainer all right enough i'm
done that is why we need to redo this
exactly the way it was with the actors
please enter
i am trina excuse me is this some sort
of weird gross like
casting couch orgy or something is it
cool if i take my shirt off
i made a pie
[Music]
imagine having an argument with her
you